what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones today I want to
talk about Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen and whether or not they will
die by the end of this series there are
thousands of theories about how this
story is going to end and most of the
popular theories involve Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen dying at some point
possibly even sacrificing themselves in
order for everyone else to survive but
I'm wondering what all of you have to
say about some of these things because
although I have received some comments
from you about the fate of some
characters I have yet to see what all of
you think about the future of two of the
most popular characters in the show and
arguably two of the most important
people in terms of the end game when
george RR martin originally wrote out a
draft for this story he had five
characters in mind that he planned on
having survived the entire story the
five characters that he said would
survive would be bran Stark Arya Stark
Tyrion Lannister Daenerys Targaryen and
Jon Snow these were the key characters
that the books were to be designed
around their survival but a lot has
changed since George wrote that original
draft he never ended up doing most of
the things that he wanted to do so this
could mean the fate of those five
characters has changed as well in fact
he may have even started to foreshadow
their deaths given the history of this
story and show it hasn't been too kind
to its conquerors and rulers but does it
mean bad news for John and/or Daenerys
the television show has also made a lot
of changes to George's story but the
showrunners Dan and Dave have said on
several occasions that George did tell
them the end of his story so I'm going
to assume they will end the show in a
very similar way they will take
different paths to get there but they
will most likely end on the same note
but that's still to be determined one of
the most popular and debated theories
revolves around Daenerys Targaryen in a
specific vision she had while she was at
the house of the undying now what she
saw in the books and what she saw in the
television show are completely different
things and she also had a lot more
visions and dreams in the books as well
but back in season 2
Daenerys had a vision where she was
walking inside the Great Hall of the red
keep
roof was completely destroyed in the
entire room was covered in snow as she
walks up to the iron throne she reaches
her hand out to touch the snow-covered
throne but as she is reaching out toward
it she suddenly hears her dragons which
makes her stop before she ever touches
it most people think that this means
Daenerys will never sit on the Iron
Throne she may rule the Seven Kingdoms
but she will never actually sit on the
throne some people even say that the
snow covering the entire room represents
Jon Snow and that he will actually be
the one to rule in the end and I must
say that Theory does make a lot of sense
to me but this isn't the only thing that
she saw after she hears her dragons she
turns away from the throne and begins to
walk away as she is leaving the room she
is suddenly standing in front of the
gate at Castle black the gate that leads
to the northern side of the wall as the
gate opens in Daenerys walks outside she
suddenly sees a tent off into the
distance which she then begins to start
walking towards when she gets inside the
tent she realizes called Drogo and their
son are inside and everything inside the
tent starts to brighten up and seems
very peaceful and happy inside unlike
the conditions beyond a wall now this
can also be interpreted in many
different ways but from what I've seen
most people think Daenerys will die at
the wall or beyond the wall fighting the
night king and after she dies she will
be reunited with her family now do you
agree with the way people have
interpreted this vision or do you think
it means something else in my opinion it
does make some sense but I'm not so sure
it's accurate another widely believed
fairy is that Daenerys Targaryen is
Nissa Nissa and I'm just going to give
you a brief description of this theory
for those of you that aren't too
familiar with it Tony Teflon also made a
video about this a while ago and he
gives a great explanation of how this
may go down I'm going to put his link
down in the description as well I highly
recommend watching that video - but
Nissa Nissa was the wife of azor Ahai
who forged the famous sword called light
bringer when darkness covered the world
Azur 'hi knew that he needed to forge a
hero's sword so he worked his ass off
trying to make the perfect sword but
every time he tried to temper the sword
it would break and after two failed
attempts he worked on one more
for a hundred days and a hundred nights
but this time he was going to use his
wife to temper the sword so he had Nissa
Nissa bare her breast and he drove the
sword right into her chest which caused
the sword to ignite creating light for a
large portion of this community believes
that something very similar will happen
to the nearest Targaryen and not only
that but Jon Snow may actually be a Zora
hide and he will need to plunge his
sword into Danny's chest in order to
create Lightbringer the ultimate sword
to be used to defeat the night king this
could also be seen as another
bittersweet way to end things there are
a lot of people who love Daenerys
Targaryen but in order for everyone else
to survive she may have to die in the
end and her sacrifice could ultimately
lead to defeating the night king
Daenerys dying would be better but
defeating the night king and given the
people a chance to restore Westeros
would be sweet while Jon Snow also plays
into this bittersweet ending because Jon
Snow may need to do something similar in
order to stop the night king from
advancing and taking over the world as
of right now Jon Snow has been the
leading voice when it comes to warning
everyone of the impending doom that is
lurking beyond the wall Jon Snow has
been rallying everyone together even
enemies because he knows without the
help of everyone they will not survive
the winter Jon Snow even died for this
cause already trying to unite the
wildlings of the Nights Watch
who had been enemies for a very long
time and for the most part Jon Snow does
have the north back under control right
now standing together and ready to fight
together but it's not enough so he's
going to have to branch out this season
and look for some more alliances before
the long night eventually sets over
Westeros even if Jon Snow is able to
unite all of the Seven Kingdoms it still
might not be enough for him to overcome
the night king and his massive army of
the Dead which may leave John with no
choice but to sacrifice himself so that
he can save the rest of humanity from
being turned into more meat for the
night Kings army when this story nears
its end there will most likely be one
final showdown between Jon Snow and the
night king and there are a lot of people
out there who say Jon will have to give
himself if he truly wants to stop the
night king from taking over everything
the night king did take interest in john
snowed during the battle at hardhome
he was definitely intrigued by what he
saw and some say the night king may have
even seen something that was familiar to
him almost as if he knew exactly who Jon
Snow was old man once said that the
night's king was a stark of Winterfell
and the brother to the king of winter
she even suggested that his name was
branded which is very interesting
because obviously Brian's name is
Brandon and John could be seen as the
king of winter right now this could
explain the connection the night King
had with John he may have even been
looking at John as if he knew him or
knew he was family this connection will
absolutely play a role in the endgame
and some people say that Jon Snow will
have to become the next night king so
that he himself can stop the army of the
dead John may have to give the ultimate
sacrifice to become the leader of the
dead and spend the rest of his life in
the lands of always winter to ensure
that the attacks on Westeros will stop
I've got to be honest with you that
would be one hell of an ending if John
had to become the next night King that
would be pretty damn crazy but while
we're on the topic of the night king
what do you all think about the
possibility of us seeing the night Queen
do you think we will ever see a night
queen in the television show I know a
few of you have said in the comments
before that you think Daenerys Targaryen
will become the night's Queen after she
is killed by the White Walkers that
would be pretty damn interesting if she
did that would be the ultimate
combination of Ice and Fire if so the
night king is basically made out of ice
in Daenerys well is basically made out
of fire at this point could Daenerys and
the night King be the Song of Ice and
Fire
I'm not so sure they're going to do this
in the show but I know they did kind of
Keys this in the long walk trailer when
Cersei exhaled and it transitioned into
the night Kings eye but I think that was
just hinting at how far winter will
reach south but comment down below if
you think otherwise I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this in my opinion I
think one of the easiest explanations
about who will live or die in this
series maybe one of the most obvious
hence we have gotten which is the
popular phrase in the show
and amongst us fans which is all men
must die that right there could be the
answer but does that mean men and women
will die John snow would certainly fit
into that phrase but would Damaris it's
not so clear with her and I could go on
all day with theories about how John and
Danny will die but I just wanted to talk
about some of the ones that I hear the
most so that I can get your opinions on
whether or not two of the most popular
characters in this show will die or not
what do you think about this do you
think everyone's going to die in the end
or do you think John and Danny will die
or both of them will die give me your
thoughts on this and if you do think
they're going to die let me know how you
think they will die even if it's tin
foil I would love to hear your reason
why before I go I want to thank the
whites king on Twitter for helping me
out with this thumbnail if you haven't
started to follow him yet and you
definitely should
he is always posting some really cool
game of Thrones artwork that he creates
and he's also going to be live tweeting
during the season with some funny
pictures and means that I think you
would like as well but anyways thanks
for stopping by and watching my video
once again we're getting so close to the
season premiere and I can't wait to
start breaking down each episode so we
can discuss any and everything going on
this season I'm really looking forward
to watching this season with all of you
and I plan on releasing all kinds of
different videos this season so I hope
you all come along for the ride I want
to give a big thanks to everyone that
supports this channel on patreon your
donations have helped me out
tremendously I was actually able to get
some new equipment for the upcoming
season so I hope you like what I'm going
to be producing within the next few
weeks when the show starts I hope you
all have a good day and I'll see you
down in comments section bye